pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
capitale officielle du canada ottawa a
fait au président de la république une
réception aussi majestueuse qu'amicale
on sait que quatre siècles d'histoire
unissent à travers les vicissitudes de
la vie des peuples
france et canada et ce sont ces liens
qu'on évoque est à ottawa comme de
québec à montréal au long de la visite
du général de gaulle émotion populaire
cérémonie officielle partout on a pu
retrouver cet accent d'une parenté à
laquelle on demeure sensible des deux
côtés de l'atlantique et la réception
offerte par le général vanier
gouverneure du canada qui fut de longues
années son ambassadeur en france n'a pas
manqué de concrétiser cette amitié
c'est devant une assemblée de choix que
le général de gaulle a dit la france
croit que l'avenir de la paix c'est à
dire l'avenir de la vie dépend de
l'europe tout entière et de l'amérique
qui ont enfanté la civilisation moderne
et qui détiennent aujourd'hui les
principales de ces ressources
la france estime que l'opposition des
régimes à supposer que l'évolution ne
tendent pas à lahti nu et ne doit pas
empêcher la coexistence pacifique
faute de quoi rien en définitive ne
sauverait l'espèce humaine
la visite au canada et l importante
préface à la visite aux états unis
à l'aéroport la réception peut passer
pour exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président eisenhower a accueillis sur
le sol d'amérique le général de gaulle
de chefs d'état mais aussi deux anciens
compagnons d'armes se retrouvaient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
washington que l'on considère comme une
capitale à ses gains d acclamer sans
mesure et ces acclamations allait non
seulement à un homme mais comme le
disent les journaux américains
un symbole qui doit inspirer les autres
nations du monde lit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certes tous les problèmes ne sont pas
résolus entre la france et la mairie
mais on peut considérer que la voix du
général de gaulle à son poids auprès du
président eisenhower et que les
différences aplani la france et les
états unis aborderont l'avenir dans
l'esprit de la vieille amitié
[Musique]
premier jeu de la communauté à
tananarive cette compétition entre
athlètes de la métropole et la tête de
la communauté donne lieu à des résultats
dans l'ensemble assez brillant ici le
3000 m steeples que remporte 1 meur au
poids le métropolite a alarmé aucune
peine à s'imposer
[Musique]
et
au disque husson vous voyez ici gagner
aisément dans une spécialité qui n'est
pourtant pas la sienne dans l'ensemble
succès partagé des métropolitains et de
leurs camarades des pays de la
communauté départ du 100 m la patte de
possibles personne ne peut battre à tout
ça il le représentant du mali ce n'est
pas un homme c'est une gale
le métropolitain collardeau reprend la
série des victoires françaises au saut
en longueur
en revanche au triple saut c'est un
nouveau succès pour le mali william
franchi 15 mètres 19 dans un fort joli
style ma foi au saut en hauteur une
surprise cet homme caoutchouc c'est un
représentant du tchad
il a 17 ans retenez bien son nom idriss
il a franchi 2 m 01
il aura encore l'occasion de faire
parler de nouveaux succès métropolitain
au 110 m haies roudnitska s'attribue la
première place non sans luttes dans les
derniers mètres
[Applaudissements]
ballast ajoute un titre à la france au
saut à la perche
[Musique]
tandis qu au javelot cyr 26 qui pousse
la coquetterie jusqu'à battre ses
adversaires de plus de 14 mètres jusqu'à
maurice herzog félicite ensuite les
vainqueurs de ces jeux de la communauté
[Musique]
reims et monaco maillot rayé joue la
seconde demi finale de la coupe de
france à collo le prince rainier la
princesse grace de monaco assister à ce
match en supporter passionné de l'équipe
de la principauté et le sourire de la
princesse donne des ailes aux joueurs
monégasques qui en font voir de toutes
les couleurs à l'équipe d'europe sans
être autrement impressionné par la
réputation de son adversaire grand
favori la coupe monaco marque le premier
but
[Applaudissements]
les rémois même temps suite des attaques
de fort belle allure
sous le regard de fontaine et de colonna
qui en ont des sueurs froides et ses
attaques de reims finissent par être
payante si atca égalise de la tête sur
un coup franc tiré par coppa
la princesse grèce ne perd pas pour
autant son sourire un sourire qui
préfigurent déjà la victoire que monaco
va remporter in extremis devant reims
voilà qui est fait monaco jouera la
finale de la coupe de france
[Applaudissements]
tout ne va pas pour le mieux au pays du
matin calme les mouvements qui ont agité
les rues de séoul la capitale de la
corée du sud ont été marqués de tragique
incident tout a commencé par une
manifestation d'étudiants protestant
contre les élections présidentielles que
l'opinion accuse d'avoir été un peu aidé
mais la police ayant réagi avec
brutalité des coups de feu ont été tirés
et bientôt cinquante mille manifestants
se déchaîner dans la ville
on devait compter plus de 70 morts et
250 blessés
tragique événement qui porte un coup
sévère au pouvoir personnel du président
sigman ray qui s'est résolu à abandonner
son poste de président du conseil pour
ne conserver que son titre de chef
d'état ou tourner son nouveau film au
secondaire en tête autrement dit les
pionniers le metteur en scène marcel
camus a trouvé au coeur du brésil un
cadre à la taille de l'entreprise
le plus extraordinaire chantier qu'on
puisse rêver celui d'une capitale que
l'homme a décidé de créer de toutes
pièces
brasilia les principaux éléments du
décor sont plantés les 28 étages des
deux building administratif dominant la
coupole concave du sénat et la coupole
convexe de la chambre des députés
la résidence présidentielle le palais de
laura les blocs d'habitations chaque
bloc est prévu pour 4000 habitants
[Musique]
pour cette capitale de l'avenir les
bâtisseurs ont imaginé la cathédrale de
l'avenir les murs seront en verre et des
églises dont l'architecturé s'inspire
des styles les plus avant gardistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ainsi une cité qui représentera le stade
le plus avancé de l'urbanisme moderne a
pris forme
là où il n'y avait voici trois ans
qu'une étendues désertes est né au bord
de son lac artificiel
la nouvelle capitale du brésil il
manquait encore un acte officiel pour
que cette ville en train de naître
succède à mario c'est apte le président
kubitschek l'a accompli en menant
inauguré brasilia où seront désormais
fixés gouvernements et administrations
[Musique]
au balcon du palais de l'europe le
président a brandi la clé de la cité à
l'intention des quelque cent mille
personnes présentes avant d'assister à
la montée des couleurs qui ont flotté
pour la première fois sur la toute neuve
brasilia capitale du brésil
[Musique]